we can see on TV and in the news Watson
who is Michael Phelps yes that
artificial intelligence is no longer
found only in the movies I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that it's
beginning to enter everyday life but can
a computer make decisions requiring
moral judgment as AI blurs the boundary
between human and machine can technology
handle the complex world we live in
look I need help I need to know more
about morality I don't know what ethics
is some powerful voices are starting to
question what we're creating I think we
should be very careful about artificial
intelligence if I were to guess at what
our biggest existential threat is it's
probably that in 2015 an open letter
urging caution in the development of
artificial intelligence and weapon
systems was signed by more than 150
experts including Elon Musk and Stephen
Hawking intelligence that will take off
on its own and redesign itself at an
ever-increasing rate
humans who are limited by slow
biological evolution could compete and
what these superseded will are machines
turn against us I mean with artificial
intelligence we are summoning the demon
patan morality be programmed
you